das deutsche weltraumteleskope rosita
hat wahrscheinlich die verlorene materie
entdeckt bei der zweiten durchmusterung
des himmels entstand damit nicht nur ein
gigantisches bild des universums sondern
es wurde eben auch diese spektakuläre
entdeckung gemacht die verlorene materie
und das ist nicht die einzige hammer
entdeckung rosita hat eine riesige
gasblase entdeckt und damit ein
gigantisches ereignis im herzen unserer
galaxie kriegs ums salz in future bis
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen das ist
wirklich eine spektakuläre aufnahme die
dem deutschen röntgenteleskop aero sieht
er jetzt gelungen ist denn es handelt
sich tatsächlich um das ganze universum
und das in einem bild vorne zu sehen die
milchstraße die von ihrer form her an
ein riesiges insekt mit orangefarbenen
flügeln und einem blauen körper erinnert
und zu den orangefarbenen flügeln kommen
wir gleich noch das ist der absolute
hammer
im hintergrund mehr als 800.000 schwarze
löcher
diese total aufnahme stammt von dem
forschungsteam um den astrophysiker
peter riedel vom max planck institut für
extraterrestrische physik in garching er
hat die vergangenen jahrzehnte damit
verbracht ein teleskop zu entwickeln
dass genau das kann uns das universum so
zu zeigen als hätten wir selbst röntgen
augen eine wirklich absolut spektakuläre
veröffentlichung denn das bild ist nicht
nur schön sondern offenbart den
fachleuten auf spannende erkenntnisse
konkret geht es um die orange gelben
insekten vögel die nördliche struktur
ist schon seit längerer zeit bekannt und
bislang galt sie in fachkreisen als die
glut einer sternenexplosion die aufnahme
von rosita liegt jetzt aber nahe dass es
sich wahrscheinlich um etwas ganz
anderes handelt das legt zumindest die
existenz der zweiten blase im süden nahe
denn das zwei supernovae fast
gleichzeitig und symmetrisch explodiert
sind dafür ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
sehr sehr klein
doch das forschungsteam hat eine
spektakuläre these um was es sich bei
diesen strukturen statt dessen handeln
könnte klar ist auf jeden fall mit den
neuen aufnahmen von rosita könnte ein
lange
bisher ungeklärtes rätsel gelöst werden
konkret geht es um den verbleib der
gewöhnlichen materie also auf der wir
hier stehen die erde zum beispiel die
fachleute bezeichnen sie ja als barrio
mische materie
zwar gibt es relativ fundierte annahmen
darüber wie viel sich von dieser
sogenannten mario nisch materie seit dem
urknall in unserem universum verteilt
haben müsste doch es gibt wohl weitaus
mehr dieser normalen materie als wir
bislang mit den mitteln die der
wissenschaft zur verfügung stehen
wirklich nachweisen konnten
wir konnten trotz intensiver forschung
nicht mal gravitative spuren für ihren
verbleib entdeckt werden und das obwohl
forschungsziel weltweit bereits mehr als
30 jahre danach so nach ansicht vieler
fachleute hält sich diese verlorene
materie möglicherweise in den riesigen
räumen zwischen galaxienhaufen und
galaxien versteckt dazu gibt es bereits
einige untersuchungen und studien
konkret geht es um die so genannten
filamente dabei handelt es sich um
unvorstellbar lange strukturen aus gas
die galaxienhaufen und galaxien
miteinander verbinden und umgeben
astrophysikerin und astrophysiker habe
bereits seit längerer zeit die vermutung
dass die verlorene materie sich hier
quasi verborgen halten könnte
theoretischen berechnungen zufolge
könnte sich hier in diesem gespinst
sogar mehr als die hälfte der gesamten
barrio mission materie befinden doch
bislang gelang es nicht dies sichtbar zu
machen eine wirkliche herausforderung
denn hier liegt wohl eine extreme
verdünnung vor fachleute gehen von nur
zehn atomen pro kubikmeter aus und solch
eine extreme verdünnung die könnten wir
selbst in den besten vakuum experiment
auf der erde niemals erreicht mit
traditionellen teleskopen und
beobachtungs methoden ist der aufwand
diese so groß räumlich verteilte materie
aufzuspüren vergleichbar mit der suche
nach einem einzigen atom in einem
durchschnittlichen großraumbüro hinweise
auf die existenz der verlorene materie
hatten zuletzt die sogenannten fast
railworks ewa bies gegeben dabei handelt
es sich um schnelle radio blitze deren
ursache bisher immer noch ungeklärt ist
nach ansicht mancher forschungsteams
könnten diese jedoch in zusammenhang mit
neutronensternen stehen gemeint sind
seltener energiereiche ausbrüche im
radio bereich des elektromagnetischen
spektrums
auch wenn diese nur wenige millisekunden
dauern werden dabei gewaltige energie
zwei australische forschende hatten
diese energie blitze in der
vergangenheit als detektoren für die
fehlende materie genutzt dazu schrieb
das forschungsteam in der studie
die strahlung der fbs wird durch die
fein verteilte materie zwischen galaxien
in ähnlicher weise gestreuten die
sonnenlicht das von einem prisma in
seine bestandteile aufgefächert wird
dieser umstand half uns dabei die
entfernung einiger etwa bis zu bestimmen
was uns wiederum aufschlüsse über die
dichte der magie zwischen den galaxien
um die fehlende materie nachzuweisen
brauchten wir nur sechs schnelle radio
blitze
doch jetzt ein weiterer großer schritt
um das jahrzehntelange rätsel rund um
die verlorene materie möglicherweise zu
lösen denn große teile der gigantischen
filamente konnten nun mit hilfe des
alten teleskops rosita endlich umfassend
sichtbar gemacht werden
rosita steht übrigens für röntgen survey
telescope array und ist eines von zwei
teleskopen an bord des
russisch-deutschen speckte ergie
weltraumobservatorium es das zweite
teleskop ist das artic sea teleskop der
russin das spektrum
weltraumobservatorium umkreist die sonne
hinter dem mond am lagrange punkt 22
hier ist die gravitation vom mond erde
und sonne genau so groß dass objekte
hier nahezu ohne antrieb ihre position
halten können auch das james webb
weltraumteleskop wird in diesem jahr
genau dorthin seine reise antreten im
oktober soll es ja der fall sein
das deutsche röntgenteleskop rosita
verfügt über den lektor gibt besonders
empfindlich auf die art röntgenstrahlung
reagieren die vom gas in kosmischen
filamenten emittiert wird
hinzu kommt dass wirklich riesige
sichtfeld womit das sonnenteleskop einen
relativ weiträumigen teil des himmels
mit hoher auflösung in einer einzigen
messung abbilden kann so entstehen sehr
detaillierte bilder auch von besonders
großen objekten wie eben den
intergalaktischen filamenten im visier
des forschungsteams dass sich vor allem
aus forschenden aus münchen und bonn
zusammensetzt stand das himmelsobjekt
namens abell 339 95 dieses ist etwa 700
millionen lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt und das gesamte system umfasst
drei galaxienhaufen doch die bilder die
mit hilfe von rosita entstanden sind
zeigen eben nicht
die zahlreichen einzelnen galaxien und
galaxienhaufen sondern eben auch die
glaselemente mit denen diese verbunden
sind ein teil davon verbindet demnach
die hauptteile von able 339 95
insgesamt scheint das gesamte filament
achtung 50 millionen lichtjahre lang zu
sein und diese bilder decken sich mit
dem was das forschungsteam zuvor in den
von ihnen entwickelten simulationen
gefunden hatte dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam die neuen e rosita bilder
des beobachteten systems ähneln
bemerkenswert den ergebnissen unserer
kosmologischen simulation das extrem
verdünnte und kältere gas im filament
scheint aus vergleichweise
unterschiedlichen richtungen zu kommen
fast nahezu orthogonal zudem heißen gas
innerhalb der galaxienhaufen und die
entwicklung seiner eigenschaften scheint
in den letzten zehn milliarden jahren
ebenfalls vergleichweise verschiedene
verlaufen zu sein
die computersimulation der fachleute
legen außerdem nahe dass solche
filamente eine große menge an verdünntem
gas enthalten dazu heißt es in der
studie weiter
unsere simulationen zeigen auch dass
sich andere gruppen und galaxienhaufen
entlang der filamente auf derartige
knotenpunkte fließt das a3 3 995 system
darstellt zu bewegen diese studien
können in einzigartiger weise dazu
beitragen den ursprung und die
entwicklung dieses galaxienhaufens und
des filaments und die besonderen
eigenschaften des gases innerhalb dieser
strukturen zu erklären doch das ist
nicht die einzige spektakuläre
entdeckung die dem röntgenteleskop aero
sie tagelang im fachmagazin nature
berichtet das deutsche forschungsteam
vom max planck institut für
extraterrestrische physik mpe in
garching von einer gigantischen gasblase
südlich der milchstraße sie erinnert an
eine ähnliche struktur die sich am
nordhimmel befindet und schon seit
langer zeit bekannt ist lange zeit
dachte man dass dieser aus einer
früheren supernovaexplosion hervor
gegangen seid doch die entdeckung der
gigantische gasblase südlich der
milchstraße liegt jetzt nahe dass sowohl
die südliche als auch die nördliche
struktur beide aus dem galaktischen
zentrum stamm in ihrer form
erinnern sie übrigens stark an eine
sanduhr so gehen die fachleute also
davon aus dass sich die neu entdeckte
struktur aus heißem gas entwickelte und
zwar aufgrund von schockwellen
diese könnten aus früheren
energiereichen ausbrüchen im inneren der
milchstraße stammen dazu der npd
wissenschaftler peter praet die scharfen
grenzflächen dieser blasen laufen
höchstwahrscheinlich entlang von
schockwellen league durch einen massiven
energieeintrag aus dem inneren unserer
galaxie in den galaktischen halos
verursacht wurden solch eine erklärung
wurde bereits früher für die fermi
blasen vorgeschlagen mit rosita ist
jetzt ihr volles ausmaß und ihrem
onkologie offensichtlich geworden
im klartext bedeutet das also dass es
sich bei der spektakulären aufnahmen von
rosita um den nachhall eines extremen
spektakels handeln muss vor etwa 20 bis
50 millionen jahren ereignete sich wohl
eine große fressattacken das gigantische
schwarze loch im inneren der milchstraße
sagittarius a stern hatte eine große
menge materie ja verspeist dabei
versprühte es wohl eine energiemenge von
achtung rund 100.000 supernovae und die
schock front dieses ereignisses läuft
seitdem durch das gas das die
milchstraße umhüllt rosita hat es
angefangen und auch diese entdeckung ist
ein wichtiger schritt um das rätsel um
die gewöhnliche war ionische materie im
universum endlich lösen zu können
die fachleute erhoffen sich nämlich
durch eine genaue analyse dieser
gasblasen den kosmischen kreislauf der
materie in und um die milchstraße und
anderer galaxien besser zu verstehen
die vorstellen selbst sind von diesen
erkenntnissen ja tatsächlich überrascht
dazu der mpi forscher michael freiberg
dank seine empfindlichkeit sowie energie
und winkel auflösung kann er rosita dem
gesamten rund genehme mit bisher
unerreichter tiefe kartieren und so auch
die südliche blase eindeutig nachweisen
alle sechs monate durch muster t rosita
den gesamten himmel und macht es den
fachleuten so möglich neue strukturen zu
entdecken mittlerweile ist die zweite
durchmusterung des gesamten himmels
abgeschlossen in den kommenden jahren so
die hoffnung will man mit aero sieht
us-hilfe fundamentale fragen des
universums beantworten denn das
röntgenteleskop soll tatsächlich eine
art kosmische inventur des universums
ermöglichen galaxien die milliarden
lichtjahre entfernt
könnten mit hilfe des röntgen teleskops
in bislang unerreichter auflösung
erforscht werden letztendlich soll dann
eine himmelskarte entstehen die nicht
weniger als die entwicklung des
universums abbildet im visier stehen
nicht nur verdunkelte schwarze löcher in
nahen galaxien und röntgenquellen wie
etwa supernova überrest in unserer
galaxie
untersucht werden sollen vor allem bis
zu 100000 galaxienhaufen also
ansammlungen von 1001 galaxien die durch
die schwerkraft miteinander verbunden
sind möglich wird deren analyse durch
das gas das sich in ihnen befindet und
bis zu 100 millionen grad heißen wegen
dieser hohen temperatur sendet es eben
röntgenstrahlung aus die fachleute
wollen durch die verteilung der
galaxienhaufen herausfinden wie sich das
universum ausdehnt wie es damals aussah
und natürlich auch wie es heute aussieht
bis zu 6 milliarden jahre soll er rosita
zurückblicken können wir freuen uns hier
wirklich sehr über jedes abo denn wir
arbeiten dafür möglichst viele menschen
die faszination von wissenschaft näher
zu bringen und ich glaube dieses video
hat das beeindruckend demonstriert und
das hier das ist auch sehr spannend
zweiter urknall
forscher entdecken gigantische explosion
im universum anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
pixum science in future bis dann bleibt
dran